google had gathered 5 exa bytes of data
between the time 2003 this type of data
has started to be produced in every two
days in 2010 and every 40 minutes by
2021 the responsibility of a data
scientist is to gather clean and present
data and have a keen business sense and
analytical ability let us have a
discussion about it in the upcoming
slides
how can you become a data scientist
as a beginner i guarantee you after
watching this video you will have a
complete understanding of how to drive
your career as a data scientist hey guys
welcome to simply learn before
proceeding please make sure you
subscribe to our channel and press the
bell icon to never miss an update today
we are going to cover significance of
data scientist in industries after that
prerequisites and technologies required
to become a data scientist and finally
salary of a data scientist before moving
forward i have a query for you which
technology is used in google maps to
predict traffic jams
deep learning machine learning natural
language processing or data structure
please leave your answer in the comment
section below and stay tuned to get the
answer now we will see how top
industries are involved in the field of
data science by 2025 the data science
industry is anticipated to grow to a
value of 16 billion dollar there is an
abundance of data science jobs all over
the world now let us list out the
crucial areas where data science is
involved
first is media and entertainment the
major players in the media and
entertainment sector is
youtube netflix hot star etc
these industries have begun to use data
science to better understand their
audience
ecommerce data science has aided retail
companies in better meeting their
expectations as they bring a unique
combination of deep data knowledge
technology skills and statistical
experience data scientists are in high
demand in the retail industries top
recruiters includes flipkart walmart
mantra etc digital marketing large
volumes of data are currently being
fetched from its user through search
pages social networks online traffic
display networks movies web pages etc a
high level of business intelligence is
needed to analyze such large volumes of
data and this can only be done with
proper use of data science approaches
top recruiters includes amazon flipkart
facebook google etc
cyber security data science and air now
being used by
the cyber security industry to prevent
the growing usage of algorithms for
harmful purposes top recruiters includes
ibm microsoft accenture cisco and many
more before moving forward what is the
answer for the question that i asked
about google map
answer for that question is machine
learning now that we know significance
of data science in industry let us
explore the prerequisites and
technologies required for a data
scientist seeing the demand of data
scientist in industry it is obvious that
the scope of data scientist is very high
there is no necessity that you should be
knowing any technology or programming
language you can be a layman too data
scientist typically have educational and
professional experiences most should be
proficient in four crucial areas first
is mathematical expertise
three concepts like linear algebra
multivariable calculus and optimization
technique are crucial because they aid
in our understanding of the numerical
machine learning algorithms that are
crucial to data science similar to that
knowing statistics is equally important
as they are used in data analysis
additionally important to statistics is
probability probability is regarded as a
must for mastering machine learning next
is computer science in the field of
computer science there is a lot to learn
but one of the key enquiries that arises
in relation to programming language is r
or python there are many factors to
consider when deciding which language to
be choose both r and python have a
comprehensive libraries to implement
complex machine learning algorithms
visualization and data cleansing in
addition to learning a programming
language you should also learn computer
science skills like
fundamentals of algorithms data
structures distributed computing machine
learning deep learning linux sql git
mongodb etc
next comes domain expertise most
individuals wrongly believe that domain
expertise is not crucial in data science
yet it is
consider the following scenario if you
are working in as a data scientist in
the banking industries and you are
knowledgeable about stock trading
finance etc this will be advantages for
you and the bank itself will favor you
over other applicants and finally
communication skill it covers both
written and oral communication in a data
science project the project must be
explained to others when finding from
the analysis have been reached this
occasionally be a report that you
provide to your team or employer at work
sometimes it must be
a block entry
it is frequently a presentation to a
group of co-workers regardless of data
science project always involves some
form of communication of the project's
findings therefore having a
communication skill is a requirement for
being a data scientist apart from all
practicing is crucial keep using
different tools also start reading
different blocks on data science start
building projects on data science which
can be added to your redzoo also you can
find many interesting courses on data
science by simply learn reward is the
result of good work now we shall discuss
salaries that a data scientist will get
it should come as no surprise the data
scientists may add significantly to any
business every step of the process from
data processing to data cleansing
requires persistent a lot of arithmetic
statistics as well as scattering of
engineering skill one of the important
factors in a data scientist industry is
experience at the beginner level a data
science will get 95 000 us dollars
annually the typical annual compensation
of a data scientist at the mid level is
between one lakh thirty thousand dollars
to one lakh ninety five thousand dollars
annually a seasoned data scientist or
the experienced data scientist will get
between one lakh sixty five thousand
dollars and
two lakh fifty thousand dollars per year
this salary will vary depending on
company the top hiring businesses in
india that will provide highest salaries
for a data scientist includes wipro
technology 17 lakh 50 000 per annum then
comes ibm which which will provide 14
lakh 68 000 per annum very famous
industry like accenture will provide 19
lakh per annum and american express will
provide 13 lakh 50 000 per annum i hope
you liked watching the video happy
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here